I just want to say before we start I've
made a horrible error oh my god let's
get to it then
all hail your new king even though
you're kind of questioning your
decisions let's hope this burns up and
fire kill it with fire
oh no it's alive and even worse well
thank you for contributing oh god no oh
what is happening
I have immediately broken everything
hello everybody thank you thank you
thank you for your contribution to my
nightmares I'm on the ground I got a
rising ball of people over there in the
wall roller coaster please stop I'd like
to get off now
okay okay apparently I can't turn off my
demon powers anymore which is good my
demon powers now have two settings whoa
and holy [ __ ] god damn it I had to
restart everything it was too broken it
can't do this I can't handle this what
is my shoulder blades popping out of my
body
okay Wow why I'm not doing anything
why okay let's stop this crazy no why I
knocked myself out of the solar system
and we're okay well I decided to visit
your fine establishment could I borrow
some money to buy some booze hello baby
how are you doing oh are you having
nightmares yet I certainly hope so shrek
is love and shrek is life give me a
smooch baby
oh no that bad that's gonna be okay
finally shrek is back in his swamp where
he always wanted to be and no donkey in
sight you can see I'm doing cartwheels
of joy right here oh he's so happy
okay alright okay okay okay okay all
right okay where the hell am i oh that's
good hey you broke it again
hello oh crap somehow I don't think this
is working correctly I wonder how well
this is not gonna work demon powers
shrek and a jetpack I wonder how badly
this is gonna go let's lie down
oh wow hey come back here I need you you
want to go bro
you really don't I'm sorry to say you
really don't hurt now we just need a
running start and no okay did not go as
planned spiraling out of control I'll be
down there in a second I'm just gonna
land on this hang glider Oh what now
what wow what the hell happened okay
immediately broken oh hello I didn't
even notice you there thanks for picking
me up I need to get out here to my home
planet the gravity and physics aren't
working too well on this one ah crap
well I'm in space and I can't move I
could do something but I think that
would be very bad oh well it's ray Oh
God okay
at least I'm not going anywhere
okay maybe I am I have no idea really it
seemed to be grounded in one spot oh god
why
okay I broke it I broke space I broke
all of space I broke everything guys
I am so sorry okay
so I think I broke the game more than it
ever even needed to be broken in the
first place and that was just with one
workshop mod so if you guys want to see
more or want me to break it even more
let me know in the comments below leave
a like if you're still enjoying the
series and as always I will see you